we have just arrived in the center of
kramatorsk to tell you it is largely
deserted now
this missile attack happened at 10 30
this morning so it's a few hours ago i'm
going to pull out of the way you can see
what's left of the missile here now it's
basically on a patch of grass outside of
the train station it's large it looks
like a ballistic missile
what we think has happened is that it
has exploded in the air over this area
because it has distributed
explosives throughout this area in
multiple locations seemingly randomly
and i'm going to ask my colleague darwin
mcluckie just to focus on the words on
the side of that
missile zadetti it means four children
or for the children
39 people we know have been killed four
of those her children themselves
the station manager here said she
thought more than a hundred
were injured we alternatively hearing
that some 300 people have been injured
as well
what we don't know is whether this
missile exploded above the airspace
above the station or whether it was
brought down by
some sort of anti-rocket or
anti-anti-missile system let's go over
to the station
but it has caused really
terrible damage
horrific damage
largely to the people who were waiting
here
everybody knows this was a train station
it's big it's multiple platforms
everybody knows that it has been used
over the last couple of days
to get tens of thousands of people in
eastern ukraine out of here and they
come here they come to this station
because getting the train is the safest
way to get out of eastern ukraine there
were thousands of people like and we
were here monday and tuesday there were
thousands of people here in the morning
as well
we've heard alternatively two to four
thousand people this morning
largely
women and children the men are not
allowed to leave men between 18 and 60
are not allowed to leave
you can see some of the damage here
so explosives from that missile have
dropped here they've i just remember
that there will have been
hundreds of people queuing up to get
inside the train station we've seen it
and they will
well they would have been killed
a lot of them
terrible damage here
you can see
people's people have brought their their
lunch their
packed lunches a few bags here
and then they would have tried
they would have been queuing up to get
into the
into the booking hall should tell you
that the police came and the ambulance
the fire service the emergency services
get came very quickly and
those injured have been taken to
hospital now bodies have been removed
but
what i think we're going to find here is
is luggage in the in the baggage hole
there we go there's a lot of luggage
there that has been left we've been here
for about five or ten minutes we've
heard people's phones ringing in the
bags obviously relatives very worried
about their loved ones they don't know
where they are
some of the bags are damaged
and we've seen people come in this
there's one gentleman there now he's
he can see his mother's bag but he can't
get a hold of his mother himself there
we are he's
he's asking for his mother's bag
i spoke to him briefly before we came to
air and he said
that his mother is not picking up the
phone he doesn't have the money to get
to the local hospital
some policemen here as well should we go
outside going onto the platform but
we're going to keep going out onto the
platform here
again parts of that missile explosive
content in that missile
landed here
by the train tracks again i don't want
to go too close because
there is blood
but again you can see the damage that it
has left people drop their possessions
it's water there's just personal
personal things
fruit apples
people are brought for the journey
the cap
everything that people
needed
to
to uh to look after themselves on the
journey to live la viv the city in
western ukraine because that is where
people
wanted to go
there
there's a couple of trains per day
come to la vie
and actually the the explosives have
damaged a train
standing out there on one of the one of
the tracks
it's now deserted there are
thousands and thousands of people have
been queuing up to get on these trains
now obviously it's completely shut the
station down and i should say that there
was a
missile strike about 30 kilometers from
here at a town called barankova that hit
the railway lines so they already had
problems in terms of getting people out
of here the railway lines had been hit
just
not too far from here about 30
kilometers away and
we heard this morning that the railway
authorities had found a way to to get
these evacuation trains out despite the
damage in this town this is
all together on a different scale and i
don't know where it will leave the the
evacuation this general evacuation
that's been going on the governor of
this region he's been saying for a
couple of weeks now that he wants
everybody to get out both for their
their personal safety and because he
expects this
this major russian offensive which is
not very far away from here at the
moment he expects
to put it
matter-of-factly expects to be fighting
in this city kramatorsk slavyansk
another city nearby expects these cities
to be at the heart of the fighting and
he doesn't want people here he does for
their own safety and he doesn't want
them to get in the way of his troops as
well
you know in terms of responsibility
the russian state media has already
claimed that the ukrainians have fired
on themselves
i think
i think
i think that is highly highly unlikely i
think that has very very little
credibility
but the ukrainian the ukrainian army and
the reserves they would draw people from
this community from kramertosk
it just begs the question would people
fire on themselves would they fire on
their their friends their family it's
just
it's just highly highly
unlikely and
and there will be an investigation i'm
sure there has to be an investigation
here because this would qualify as a war
crime uh under the geneva conventions
this is a attack on civilians clearly an
attack on
civilians
everybody knew
what was happening at this train station
tens of thousands of people have passed
through
here we can go to another section um if
you want to stick with us
just sure
okay let's just go over on to another
side of the station just gives you gives
you an idea of how
the explosives from this rocket from
this missile dropped in
different locations
around the station itself
you can see some of the windows have
been
some of the windows have been broken
there are shrapnel holes in the walls
powerful powerful blast
and it must have been absolutely
terrifying i mean there will have been
thousands of people at the station i
mean when we were here we saw hundreds
of people here on the benches
standing with their bags
waiting for the trains to come
you know slightly competitive really to
try and get on these trends there's so
many people trying to get out there's
not enough seats on each individual
train for the people who queue up
then again here you can see again there
would have been people sitting here
waiting completely unaware
of what was about to happen
again it's the same thing
possessions that have been left
i can see fruit and apples
water stuff that people have brought for
the journey anybody would bring for for
a long journey and it is a long journey
to la viv
there's also blood
there's a
small crater here you can see
probably where the explosives hit
punched a small hole
in the platform
again
some broken windows as well must have
been terrifying for the people who are
here it is now deserted we spoke to the
station manager she said people
those people who were able left very
quickly and it is absolutely
deserted now few ukrainian soldiers here
a few people who belong to the railway
but um
yeah you know this will have
significantly set back the evacuation
efforts going on here and they were in
full swing they've been
in full swing for the whole week i think
tens of thousands of people will have
passed through here since since sunday
or monday in an absolute disaster here